hey what is up everybody it's animac
here for anime uproar and we are at a
massive crossroads in the mha manga
things are getting extremely hype but
also extremely dark and
deadly bakugo just paid a very high
price for choosing to fight shigeraki in
close quarters he is severely injured
and he could be killed at any moment on
top of that the big three are together
again and they're about to engage
shigaraki in an attempt to save bakugo's
life but this has raised major death
flags for the big three as well and then
of course there's all for one deku toga
and dead man's parade dobby's shiny
chest and so much more so let's get into
it you guys know what to do leave a
quick like and comment right now to
support the video in the youtube
algorithm and if you want to support the
channel directly take a second to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
if you haven't already i know it sounds
like a little thing but it's actually a
big thing on youtube and it helps us out
a lot finally this video will of course
contain boku no hero manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned chapter 359 begins with a
colored cover page that shows all for
one apparently reverting back to his
prime something that was already
strongly hinted at a couple of chapters
ago we see all for one grasping for deku
as an angry deck who grasps for him as
well and all for one still seems to have
a part of his normal villain costume on
although it is in pieces as if it's
either coming apart or putting itself
back together but underneath the pieces
of his costume we can see that the
injuries he suffered in his first big
fight against all might have been healed
his hair is back his face and his eyes
are back and he looks more sinister than
ever even though the latest chapter
doesn't show us what exactly happened
with all for one and endeavor because
the focus is on the fight against
shigaraki this is definitely some
serious and dark foreshadowing on the
cover page not only is shigaraki an
absolutely overpowered monster with an
artificially engineered superhuman body
but now the original all for one is
apparently back in his prime that is
just too much for the heroes to handle
and deku really does need to do
something fast or else the villains will
do irreparable damage as ops deku is
with one for all and all of his
different quirks he can't bring people
back from the dead and if he doesn't get
back to ua soon he might arrive to find
that some of his best friends and
classmates are no longer among the
living speaking of deku's friends the
previous chapter ended with bakugou
using his new ultimate support item the
suppressive heavy mobile unit straffe
ponzer to launch a massive cluster bomb
attack right at shigaraki the attack was
launched at very close range with the
intent of dealing as much damage to
shigaraki as possible without destroying
the entire floating ua compound and in
order to achieve this bakugou had to
take the risk of getting up close and
personal to shigaraki but more on that
later in the latest chapter we get a
glimpse of what is actually going on
behind the scenes or i guess under the
scenes of the floating ua building
heroes and hero students are rushing to
repair damaged equipment in real time in
order to keep the ua flying as it
continues to sustain damage from the
battle taking place just above the
school grounds the fact that chicago
turned himself into a huge clump of
mutated flesh is weighing the ua
building down and it is rapidly losing
altitude those who came up with this
plan clearly didn't take into account
all of the extra weight that shigaraki
would bring with his mutation power so
now everyone has to work extra hard just
to keep the ua from crashing to the
ground as all of this is happening the
ua management course students are making
a documentary about everything that's
going on because they want to document
this epic battle and make it available
for future generations of heroes uh i
honestly forgot that this department
even existed and this whole scene of
them documenting what's going on seemed
kind of weird and tacked on but okay
whatever i guess horikoshi wanted to
remind us that yeah this department
actually exists possibly because some of
them are not going to make it through
this fight so instead of just having
like a bunch of faceless casualties
horikoshi is reminding us of who these
guys are that is just speculation on my
part in terms of these guys not making
it but we'll have to wait and see what
horikoshi plans on doing with these guys
in the end back on the battlefield just
above the ua we see the end result of
bakugo's massive explosive attack which
he launched mere inches from shigaraki's
face bakugo did not want to attack from
a distance he wanted to get up close and
personal even though this obviously
posed a massive risk to his own body but
bakugo didn't decide to do this because
he wanted to stick it to shigaraki by
getting up in his face he decided to
take this risk because the nature of
bakugou's attack required him to get up
close in order for the attack to be as
effective as possible we then see a
massive blast erupt in the spot that
bakugou attacked shigaraki but although
the explosion is extremely powerful and
massive most of the explosive force
drops off the edge of the ua compound
and it doesn't destroy the compound
itself several students were concerned
that bakugou's attack will do just that
that it will damage the ua structure or
the power lines that they've been using
to keep the force field up but kaminari
tells them not to worry he says that
despite his over-the-top hot head
persona bakugo is actually extremely
careful and meticulous in battle he is
not the type of guy who would disregard
his surroundings and recklessly put his
allies in danger and i mean that is 100
true bakugo deliberately used a highly
condensed blast that maximized the
energy output while avoiding collateral
damage to the environment as much as
possible but in order to attack
shigaraki with such a highly condensed
blast he had to get as close to
shigaraki as possible as i mentioned
earlier as a result shigaraki was able
to grab bakugo's arm which allowed him
to avoid the full brunt of the attack
bakugou also came close enough for
shigaraki to seriously injure him not
only did he grab and injure bakugo's arm
but he also seriously injured the right
side of bakugo's face which is now
covered in blood and yet even after that
impressive attack which was clearly the
strongest attack we've ever seen from
bakugou shigaraki says that he still has
no interest in bakugo best genius miruko
and the other heroes try to jump in and
help bakugo out but shigaki just repels
them all using more of his creepy
mutation powers he tells them that the
only thing that trying to fight against
him up close and personal is going to
get them is a taste of what it's like to
be smashed by a power that rivals all
might we then see an injured bakugo on
the ground and he seems to be second
guessing himself internally he is asking
himself whether the gap between him and
shigaraki really is so vast that he can
never bridge it no matter how hard he
tries after all bakugou believes that he
had just given his all to that attack
that this was his absolute best and yet
it wasn't even close to being good
enough to take shigeraki down now to be
fair shigaraki did suffer some burns and
other injuries including to the right
side of his face and at the moment he
can't regenerate because of his quirks
being erased so that damage is still
there but realistically shigaraki is
still in much better shape than bakugou
then as if to add insult to injury
shigaraki tells bakugo that the only
thing that makes him even a little bit
interesting is the fact that he is
deku's best friend
wow bro
wow
this is literally the worst possible
thing that you can say to bakugo
shigaraki basically just called bakuga a
side character to his face and if
there's anything that bakugou rejects
it's the idea that deku is the main
character and that he is just a side
character as shigaraki approaches
bakugou probably intending to finish him
off for good we see that aizawa is
extremely worried he screams at mandalay
to report on deku's status but mandalay
isn't able to reach him because the
electromagnetic waves from the barrier
are messing with her signal so all she
can hear right now is static izawa cries
out for one of the other heroes to
please save bakugou before shigaraki can
reach him bakugou still has his whole
life ahead of him he still needs to
graduate from the ua and then pursue his
dream of becoming the number one pro
hero and the main character but it looks
like the ones who are going to help
bakugou are not the pro heroes but
rather fellow hero students sun eater
and edger have both taken damage in this
fight already but they step up to the
plate to fight again sun eaters says
that he also wants to have a proper
graduation ceremony so they have to get
principal nezu to throw them one after
all of this is over the students then
wonder if they're going to make it is
their eventual graduation going to be an
actual graduation ceremony or is it
going to be like a v tuber graduation if
you know what i mean and that is when my
boy meteo emerges from the ground he
says that he doesn't know whether the
three of them are going to make it
through this but whatever happens they
will keep everyone else safe until deku
arrives as the big three prepare to take
on shigaraki in order to save bakugou's
life the chapter comes to an end and yo
mirio is finally here speaking of which
where was he all this time was he like
helping out beneath the surface with all
the technical stuff in terms of keeping
the ua afloat or was he preparing some
secret strategy for defeating shigaraki
as arguably the single strongest hero
student who doesn't have one for all you
would think that media would have been
one of the first to be sent out to fight
shigaraki so could the delay in sending
meteo out be related to some special
strategy i mean theoretically meteos
quirk should be really effective against
shigaraki's mutations because at the end
of the day they are just a physical
power and meteo can pass through
physical objects at will i honestly
can't wait to see what the big three
have in store for shigaraki and i do
feel that meteo probably has a strategy
up his sleeve a strategy that will
involve tapping into the full potential
of his quirk however i do want to talk
about what sun eaters said that whole
thing about hoping that they will
actually get to graduate together
because that could end up being a major
death flag like yes right now the story
is leading us to believe that bakugou is
the one in immediate danger of losing
his life but bakugo is such a major
character that i just don't see him
dying in this battle i'm not saying it's
impossible but i would be extremely
surprised if that happened that said i
would not be surprised if say sun eater
or negede ended up dying in this fight
especially after that somber comment by
sun eater i certainly hope that media
won't die since he's literally one of my
favorite characters in the entire series
and he's been through so much and arie
needs him okay eddie needs her big bro
meteo so he has to make it anyway let me
know what you guys think down in the
comments below could bakugou actually
die in this fight could one or more of
the big three die oh and no i don't
think that bakugo's facial injury means
that the second one for all user is
bakugo from the future who went into the
past i know this is an extremely popular
theory but i feel like it's a different
type of injury and the theory in general
is too crazy for me to get on board that
aside i am now extremely curious about
what's going on with all for one and
with deku and how all of these different
plot points are going to come together
in the end remember we now have at least
5 major plot points unfolding at the
same time we have the battle against
shigaraki the battle against all for one
deku trying to get back to the ua the
battle on okuto island where toga could
initiate dead man's parade at any moment
and of course the battle against dabi
which appeared to be over but then
dobby's chest began to light up in a
strange way when you think about all of
these different plot points and how they
all need to actually be resolved and
then come together in the end i feel
we're still a long ways away from the
final chapter of this manga let me know
if you agree down below i always love
hearing from you if you enjoyed this
boku no hero video and you want to see
more in the future leave a quick like
and comment it only takes you a second
but it helps me out a lot and if you're
new to anime opera or maybe you watch
our videos but you just haven't had a
chance to subscribe yet do me a quick
favor and make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications it might
seem like a little thing but it's a very
real way of directly supporting the
channel and it's totally free you can
also hit me up on twitter and instagram
at animeopror i want to give a big thank
you to all of our anime uproar patrons
for making videos like this one possible
special thank you to kyle salisbury this
man is an absolute mad lad and a
disciple of lord twego himself and i
can't forget all of our the one tier
patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans including alpha sigma pate
heffa the red-haired fox hinokami and
water the toasted chi corey mcgowan the
fallen chosen orihime wukong dante
tinnell and big buddhist finally thank
you also to our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
angel cruz alicia octor bonnie parks fat
boy games kaido might be a duck alivania
and anime s codem if you guys enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value to you consider supporting us on
patreon as always thank you guys so much
for watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys